[Applaudissements]
mais non c'est moi je suis ventriloque
dans ce métier il ya trois catégories de
gens et censure la troisième génération
qui assure que beaucoup de talent et
qu'on aurait préféré ne pas connaître
parce qu humainement ils sont pâles au
niveau de leur talent gérard connaît
comme moi il ya c'est donc il ya ceux
qui n'ont aucun talent et qui sont
imbuvables n'en parle même pas et puis
un cercle très fermé des gens qui ont
beaucoup de talent et qui sont des gens
biens sans les conseils doit dès demain
mais quand et c'est parti allait michel
drucker sur mtv et welsh est gros boeuf
ou bien celle ci me ch'uis michel aux
platines ce soir de la bible on veut
redonner le dernier 55 fait péter la
sono
ben laden mais les graves qui fait
spéciale dédicace à tous les poteaux
partie troupe big band aura écouté ce
sont les tabacs en produire
[Applaudissements]
benjamin castaldi ou nikos aliagas
benjamin que vous avez l'on avait lancé
on va de deux abonnements ceni conseil
[Applaudissements]
et je signais perdu